to the beautiful occasion we got to jump
into that ring you don't say to settle
this was the for all lost my maid no
have up stepping up to the plate so
let's get it right to it fellas you know
say hello help out the first thing is
you know he was talking about the whole
performance enhancers okay me when it
comes to debating or babbling or
anything is use people use logic against
them you understand so if you're playing
against me then if I'm using
performances and other stuff telling me
that I need these days or it's in the
job done sauce and so that's the case
the best case you should the way you're
talking you're talking as if you know if
you're going to guess me then you'll be
able to write me out now you don't say
because I need these performance
enhancers to get the job done so you
know it's just be me versus you and you
go sea wheedies the performance
enhancing and obviously doesn't eat
because I slept
I say one thing one what actually is two
things you show me first of all you not
the person I thought you was your real
dude that's that's racks all right all
right that's one 100% to use all time
you text me send me a friend invite and
all that you ain't Doug you sly you move
to the side no matter what the situation
is you still stood up to the plate then
you took a your business I can't say
nothing against that you know as a real
Jean like I don't know how you like I
said he showed me things about the game
that I know about the game and I respect
his gangster you understand it was
yeah another thing is this is say um
when he was fighting I was also telling
him because he was a Papa talk about the
cup that day and I like that it's not
does not do that let's get everything as
well as possible for the podcast but one
thing that I want to show him is this
because because I utilize his words
against them by putting my own skills to
the test to use given a situation the
way this podcast is going now if we
never would have played and stuff like
that then I would have came on a podcast
and then this would have been very a
pinch in it had been going back and
forth and ittle bit more of a rah rah
type of thing as opposed to a growth
more made in a respectable moment a
learning moment to understand one
another
so you got all forgot ways to break that
ice so I wanted to create a scenario
that the moment we come on the podcast
it's already driven by respect so we
could actually achieve what the goal is
and in order to get respect to have him
play me so I can show him that I really
do this because there's a lot of people
out there industry now that really don't
know how to play games because they're
not game journalists they're just
journalists they happen to land a gig in
the game industry and a lot of people is
like that so in my situation I don't
mind showing improvement because I've
been playing games I was poor so I can I
feel like in my situation I earned the
right to do it about what
how long what because like a backup
whatever I say in Indy given situation
and I've been proven 20 and again
because it was approached to the round
table at the time so anything that you
guys you got off the top right now I
want I want you to explain
okay so I'll make this quick I will make
this long-winded the first thing is when
I play card I played it in our packs
this stuff right there and I played it
and others don't
I love it the response of the controller
is the graphics everything ah style I
love this I played it I knew is hard but
I'll care is fun it was fun when I died
I was great then when I play the first
string the first stream I play
everything that I played the first time
when I'm doing a demonstration to the
people I play it in his raw form you
know saying just so he could see it this
stuff like that CIA is okay I'm just
showing you the game and what it is
that's that's the first impression of
the string and that's when I did the
second string because the game is so
hard no matter how much a person died
gets to a point in time where you do
want to see progression because you got
a bit it's um people are sitting there
watching you so I get exactly what I
mean oh this is one night when I was
playing watchdogs to when it first came
out and it got to this point where I
didn't know how to get through this
puzzle cuz you know they got the arm and
watch those they got these like puzzles
with the arm with hacking it's like a
twister boxes and make the lineup is
engagement
cuz at this point way just keep them be
stuck on this one point you want to show
the duration of the game is where yeah
exactly yours for the progression of the
game and if you end up and again that's
very very difficult and also on a pet
again even with a Chico I'm playing as
the cheapening there anyway I'm still -
I'm still trying to like
myself you know get hit yeah I'm still
trying to challenge myself to so we're
watching it that people X wait how did
you hit like so many times C which is
away and he's still getting hit so my
biggest is still if the train there can
I try in the wind but for the sake of
progression and you watching the stream
and you want to be entertained you've
got to have that balance and then the
third thing is developers themselves use
these modifications on their games when
we showed it to us right a lot of times
so I write o the like I remember when he
was showing are where they were showing
your arm infamous second son all to us
it was this particular level when the
waiting was doing it was no difficult so
they were like turn on certain things
that you will not have access to in the
game at this particular stage in the
game but they will give you access to it
just to demonstrate to you what is going
to be like when it come out and blah
blah blah and what you can do in this
net
recently I was playing Wolfenstein two
at an event here in New York and they
gave us all these new abilities that you
will not have a point in the game but
they let you test it out so my thing is
I just want to show you options I'll
show you I want to show you how it is
the raw form the first impression but
also I want to show you what it's like
just to see the progression of games so
there's engagement so you gotta have a
balance of the two that's one it is Oh
batiko to beat the game no you tried
beating games I was four years old the
game I think I actually said that it's
like like you know he wanted his
viewership to say to see the progression
of the game because if you look at it
that when he was streaming that which
you know there was there wasn't a lot of
people you know as far as you are
hip-hop with you know because of the
stuff I know I know damn well I would
I can understand that could you because
I had said that on the podcast like you
know you could show your viewership
something that no one else is saying
because everyone else is still on like
the first set of bosses right you know
I'm sorry I mean like I said I'm glad
you got in front of it because like I
said at the end of the day you know the
way I looked at it and way some people
did like it I said okay he's not doing
an official review he's showing his user
base at the game how fun it is and the
title of your title wasn't like official
review I'm saying so as far as I could
see it was old but I know there was a
tremendous backlash from some of the
community because of that and what I do
have to respect from hip-hop is that he
was completely transparent he's
completely honest like yeah I used it
and I'm doing it to showcase the game
I'm saying it's not like you know I'm
saying any other reason for that so
that's why I'm so proud of you like you
just you know tell people is this like
you know and this is the same like cocky
anything just be truthful all right like
do I want to do okay most people who do
with a tool or they hold themselves to a
certain scrutiny of what the insider
industry will see as fit if you try to
if you try to be a disrupter in the
field if you try to lead if you're
trying to do things a certain way you
can't worry about what other people do
or worry about what other people say you
don't say it at the end at the end of
the day until the resume commands my
resume don't talk to me but you know
saying this is respect and it as well as
situations where if I tell somebody to
go back up here cuz it's great when I
use a cheat code or not over a million
people brought that [ __ ] so obviously
where I've been saying what's accurate
based on how people voting with their
wallets
you're insane I'm saying snow it's like
at the end of day you know it doesn't
matter because if I'm reviewing the game
I'll review a game based on if it has a
story then I will do a based on a story
and I'm gonna say something else because
somebody said I don't know who said this
but you don't have to finish of
okay to be to review it I'll give a damn
what you say because it's music slightly
it's gonna give you a deeper definition
from the gaming standpoint so if
somebody play a song for me it's a three
pin a song after the first 20 25 seconds
then a popping next you be taught the
puppy do retort the 50 cent and all of
these cats and I've been around trust me
this is how all right that's one two we
are expert at something like I'm an
expert in games
I can play a game right for like a few
hours a game the graphics is hot it's
not the gameplays was a response time is
hot it's not the sound effects is don't
is high or it's not like oh the fun
factor is how it's not based on those
parameters and valuables I don't need to
finish the game to let you know how to
[ __ ] feel leo's I feel within the first
20 30 minutes of a game the moment you
move the controller you could serve as
good a night cuz that's what you want to
continue playing this [ __ ] so at the end
of the day that's what matters
okay you just give a brief synopsis of
the game and you like yo if you fill the
game then you know this is how it is or
whatever and if it's a story based game
you're not gonna go too much into the
ending of the game you're just gonna
allow them to play the game and get to
the end of c4 they self
oh yeah absolutely can I don't want to
spoil it but what I will say is like if
we're playing a game and even if it's a
story game but when I was streaming
Uncharted stuff like that I was like yo
this is crazy because they're watching
me they like they watching me look at
the story portion of that part of the
game and I'm like yo this is crazy this
net and then some people may not have to
get about yo this is crazy because such
method you should go back and play this
game and then you appreciate this one
more like how I appreciate it and it
gets them excited because they like play
this [ __ ] you're serious so I'm just
different like some people wanna Tom do
not put me in the same box or booboo as
any other journalists that do review
because their review is very the review
is very focused rated it stays a certain
way my reviews is very wrong you don't
know what you'll get for me because when
I play the game I just put that [ __ ] in
my initial feeling of the game if I like
it or if I don't like it
you got to see that because I give my
first impression of the [ __ ] stream
again I never played it before until I
see the whole mmm my question you know
in reference to that is I'm gonna flip
your same analogy know in a sense that
I'll forget said you get a because I've
had situations where I cop out right and
that it's like that sometimes I do not
like that track one I need to hit for
you to be there you'll be popping and
like sometimes I say try to attract to
ain't really it and I'm like and then by
like track three four and then the rest
of the album is stuff you know there so
at the same time I do soldiers but I've
been in scenarios where a game I've
played may have not started I started
off really slow and they start to heat
up
you don't say where's the flip but you
have a really strong and then you get to
so it is that's something I definitely
want to bring on as far as the show as
far as you know having that discussion
even more and getting deepening into it
even more because at the end of the day
I do agree what you're saying at the end
of it you control your medium and your
boy should move how you move you know
I'm saying
so that's crack
saying that no one's disputing that and
at the end of the day you are one of the
few journalists who actually puts it on
one who actually will say look I play
these games I get busy I do this you
know I'm saying and that's what I wanted
to get out of this as well because a lot
of these dudes don't play games actually
everybody knows me for me always know
that pro golfers and everything I do say
that's my slogan in the day I love none
of this [ __ ] means anything unless
there's love in it unless you are
willing to UM be a brother a friend to
anyone that you encounter in life period
so at the end of the day none of this
[ __ ] means it doesn't mean anything
unless you're doing the right things
with it that's it that's how I am as a
person as a friend as a father as a son
or whatever like this is who I am I love
I love this this so you know they took
him from a space of whatever until you
talk to me and meet me it's AK with me
you have no choice but to love me
did you accept why after all the the
whole keppa thing was over did you
expect the the reaction that you got or
was it like did you get blindsided
button good question
oh it is a great question I'm not a give
my son today I'm actually expected it
because I know nobody else to do this
[ __ ] and it sounds somebody do something
other people have some sort of fear of
doing or just written do then is going
to be questioned because most people are
followers like 98% of people are
followers and if you don't follow what
other people are following then able to
get you as out best and if you do
outcast you will get called out so my
thing is I'm the kind of person called
me and called me out all the time
because only like pulling me out it's
because you have a fear I'm doing the
things that I actually do so indirectly
you really wanna be me that's what it is
you think I'm able to break like I'll be
breaking stories before a lot of the big
conglomerate people because they just
question that you brought up in terms of
the album it's the beginning in the end
is said to be highs at the end okay so
here's two things I like the world
incident one everything is always based
on you know one's opinion so just so
just as well as you said the album could
spot good it end up that somebody could
say well nice not all bad and own good
or everything is their own experience
how they receive it absolutely
you know saying objective so what I
would say is when I play a game and I'm
playing um you know a story this
to you or how their story affects you
it'll matter what I tell you about the
store I could say the story is hot and I
can play the holy [ __ ] and you can peek
everything I said was garbage no matter
yes so it's all subjective so the only
thing that I can tell you that snores
effect as opposed to something that's
objective is when we see or screen in
terms of the graphics what we hear with
our ears in terms of the sound design
and what we feel when we control if is
responsive or not that's the closest
then you could get to effect so when
somebody pick it up they can feel they
can respect what you're saying the most
so when it comes the story Numenta the
whole [ __ ] or not there's gonna be
people that will receive things
differently for example the girl delhi
gin when she gave you seven a seven out
of ten
to me that's how she felt she felt I'm
the kind of person challenge your own
theories on things because I don't like
inconsistencies STP boom they will
review and say older Motown's was too
long for this game ending alt called a
few points to a huge point on that is
there is a lot of the industry that I
wouldn't say they're bought but their
thoughts are hugely manipulate summers
boy are you stupid
first of all I never work for company in
this industry ever did partnerships with
people I got partner shoes now but that
just means that I'm equal in fact that
I'm equal I say what I want I do it away
and the reason why the rock with me
because they know that when they Rock we
you will get the world you can get the
water you get a level of quality
industry you see a lot of similarity
between Mia 50 so 50 was killing them on
destroyed so I'm the kind of person when
it comes to that you ad you and I see
people trying to lay egg you wanna make
you feel good about what you do we not
gonna just do traditional podcast hasn't
talked we need some action talk
let's get in the ring let's see who's
the best you know coach I love it
we love to see that hip hop with the
question law and I put
boom
also just just just to say to King and
just you know everybody out there um
first love you guys podcast like you
don't say I know that you know I
appreciate you so much I really do but I
really wanted to say and you know I came
over here I was like you know the reason
why I set it up the way I set it up and
this was this all silly before in the
chat okay but I said I'm gonna tell you
when you're on the podcast so the thing
is anytime somebody plays out in like
trash about something like if you talk
trash about something that you fully
don't have 100% information on when you
already put yourself in a position yeah
you already put to something a
disadvantage and a submissive position
because now I get the control called the
whole thing play out because but the
banter wasn't all equal is all you
coming at me I never said no to you out
there like that it gave me the advantage
to say well says you said this is this
I'm a cheater I'll put everything on my
terms and stuff like that what you
thought was an advantage because people
was bigger you because everybody is this
they can understand that accept the
challenge or take a challenge and you
got to back your words up so right I
said whatever I said about the man
so me the man you know had I wasn't
winning would [ __ ] we would see this is
where this is where the difference is
and this is how you won and I'm gonna
tell you how you want
you came from it in a standpoint of love
and let me teach this man something I
came from a standpoint is oh you say
what he challenged me I'm gonna break
him down coming at it in the have a look
at you came at it with you was at peace
with it when I was at rage with it you
understand so when you have rage with it
of course you at a disadvantage and you
have peace with it so that's why first
of all when we got on the air will mean
you was chopping it up when you release
the foot I love the fact that you can do
no matter what like that was more than
anything when I saw a pop up on the
screen and it was like hip-hop is like I
really feel like you say you have stuff
that you had to do and you is doing so
I'm pretty sure you got stuff in some
places that you have to be or whatever
but you took a timeout Thanks because we
gotta give it up we give it up when we
gotta give it up that's one thing about
the Lord's you know we always respect
everybody
great atmosphere and also you know we
gotta get you on the follow-up you know
say I also want to promote what you're
doing cuz I like I said a lot of people
to me don't give each other a lot of
respect out here in this in it field and
what would have the program platform we
trying to build you a you a lord at what
you do you know I'm saying so thank you
all
exactly you go come on we gonna promote
you we gonna have you tell us what's
going on with you we gonna talk game we
got some fun
yes sir yeah I appreciated me in the
last day that the last thing I'll say is
one of the most important things about
this whole scenario that took place is
creating positive reference points so I
give you the example right it's just
like if you see the game now you're
saying you are you going to spawn from a
save point so I feel like my life do
people need to be positive reference
points so each person that I encounter
is like a save point in my life I don't
understand I'm saying slow so the way
out so the way I utilize it is when I'm
talking to King I'm like yo King all of
the experience that leaders with me if
somebody say something about me and they
don't know me over here it creates a
positive reference point to people so I
encourage people that's listening to
this podcast like you know right now be
make sure that your actions and your
love is utilize as a safe point through
others when they encounter you because
that is the only way that who you are
can go viral in a positive light that
could change people lives even if you
never spoke to them utilize people in a
positive way that's a fact and that's it
the King shot pop that was love we gonna
get you back on the show bro we're gonna
work out
[Laughter]